[Musique]
et maintenant retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de papy grenier pilates et
papineau les enfants vous êtes vivant
actuellement ils sont vivants jeu que
j'ai perdu mon port et les papilles une
histoire est ce que je vous ai raconté
la fois où j'ai fait un jeu vidéo
regardée mais ils ont refusé la drogue
par les développer un mythe est un homme
fort et d'ubisoft qui va encore changer
les doublages rapide
alors est ce que je vous ai parlé de la
fois où j'étais agent spécial du
gouvernement de l'unité renard c'était
en 1999 et on appelait serpent soline
parce que j'avais une énorme capacité à
m'infiltrer comme un serpent c'est a
commencé alors que je me filtrer un sous
marin dans une base ennemie détenus par
des terroristes
le colonel me faisais le briefing
détailler tous les ennemis que j'allais
devoir affronter psycho mantis et ses
pouvoirs télépathiques puissant
snipers tireurs d'élite super mais
dangereux c'est utile ce à quoi les
vachement bonne c'est super important
comme un faux je devais me free trade à
la base mais pour cela il y avait qu un
seul chemin l'ascenseur il y avait des
gardes partout
un orage manques il y avait un défaut de
conception dans leur match ce qui me
rendait la mairesse et grâce à mes
talents d'infiltration je suis
rapidement arriver à l'intérieur aucun
gars ne me repérer je peux appeler
censure
voilà frais ninja il n'y avait pas que
le colonel d'ailleurs il y avait aussi
la petite meiling elle démissionne
ravi de vous connaître au smic un
concepteur en technologie militaire de
renommée mondiale a le droit d'être
aussi mignonne mais papy comment tu
pouvais savoir qu'elle était mignonne
s'ils s'étaient branchés sur ton oreille
tu avais pas d'image du coup habile pas
cool et yavuz docteur nguyên thi si vous
revenez entier peut-être que je vous
laisserai une fouille et jusqu'aux os
bien tout le monde baiser avec tout le
monde je vais été envoyés ici sans jeu
qu'une heure mais j'avais pas écouté le
briefing le seul truc que j'avais gardé
c'était mes clopes
comment vous avez c'est dans mon estomac
hockey fait attention hélicoptère ya un
druze pas ce problème colonel violence
missiles sol air stinger
comment vous avez fait de votre estomac
aussi non attendez je cherche la
démission en mai fit ronde à la base
j'avais trouvé la personne que j'étais
venu chercher libéré il m'avait parlé de
ce que je redoutais le plus
lemay seul giro ce que je m'apprête à
vous dire est top secret nous étions en
train d'expérimenter un nouveau type
une arme qui révolutionnera seconde toi
mobile nucléaire
avec la capacité de lancer une attaque
nucléaire n'importe où et de n'importe
où oui partout
évidemment pas de l'eau parce que ça ne
fait pas ni désert parce que ça ne vole
pas pas de surface trop meuble ni les
bons parce que c'est un peu lourd et les
rivières ça passera derrière mais par
contre s'il est sûr une grande plaine
bien dégagée sans trop d'armes rapporte
que dieu nous vienne en aide
papy salaires tous pourris comme arman
au contraire ça fait peur
en plus il s'appelle metal gear rex
comme un t-rex de tipis m'expliquer
pendant vingt minutes les dangers du
nucléaire je suis pas venu pour le cours
d'histoire à faire là dedans tu l'étais
montrer look
ouais les gardes étaient très courts
j'avais un peu de mal à comprendre h été
compliqué alors je faisais souvent
répété les gens s'il n'y avait pas eu
cette révolution la révolution les
cartes clés carte que si quelque part
au deuxième sous-sol faut pouvoir et s
il vous plait c'est super énervant
énervant finalement le type est mort
devant moi et j'ai rencontré m'érige une
autre prisonnière à la v12 sécu bâton
quoi c'est tout ce dont je me souviens
même les comptes-rendus avait dit oui
c'est le chef des terroristes
ou lui ressemblait à s'y méprendre vous
parler de ce mec
le chef des terroristes ouais vous le
connaissez c'est pas votre frère au mois
enfin soyez sérieux liquid snake serait
mon frère à moi solide tech mais non ça
serait complètement nul comme scénario
avant de trouver liquid snake et le
métal jir jeu devrait affronter chacun
de ses lieutenants tout d'abord aux
flottes noces de la gâchette
et puis en sortant jamais rencontré au
tac aux scientifiques fans de [ __ ]
animations vous n'avez parlé de choses
super importante concernant la mission
hélène façon de tortiller sont derrière
ça pour la carte
elle a vraiment joli derrière papy quoi
jeu super important ensuite c'était au
tour de psycho mantis télé pinte qui
pouvait lire le passé des gens
[Musique]
heureusement que c'était pas sur pc papy
quoi ils pouvaient aussi déplacer les
objets se téléporter tirer des baleines
enflammé vc c'est bizarre et contrôler
et mentalement les gens à py s'est passé
un télépathe
c'est grâce aux nano machines ta gueule
c'était un combat acharné et psycho
mantis avait parfaitement utiliser ses
pouvoirs
[Musique]
mais finalement j'ai réussi à l'emporter
au prix de durs combats
et puis comme anti ch est venue mourir
d'ennui province mais si je pars ce
masque à gaz
si pour éviter d'atteindre les temps
c'est déjà logique
laisse moi te raconter mon passé en fait
c'est à dire que là j'ai 20 ans que
duclair a arrêté alors la première
personne dont jésus les pensées dans son
coeur jeune élu de haine et mépris pour
moi tient en temps la piana senailly
pietri tout pour moi avec syco menti ce
malgré le fait que vous ayez tué plein
de gens aient pris le contrôle de mes
rides en la poussant à se suicider se
faire violer avant de me tuer je trouve
étonnant qu les en fait j'étais presque
arrivés au métal jir il ne me restait
que quelques ennemis à affronter
heureusement les gars étaient pas un
problème au maire dit le loin et sur le
chemin merrill s'est fait abattre par
sniper wolf des lieux dans deux éclipses
blake
il fallait que je la retrouve pour
sauver mary le problème c'est que le
trajet était obstrué par une meute de
loups mais heureusement j'étais bien
équipé vous voulez pas un camouflage
optique plutôt snec pas besoin j'ai ce
qu'il faut mais où est il
du coup pour adapter ce technique au
bout il suffisait que je me fâche pisser
dessus et l'odeur de piste de loups
faisait que les loups m'aimait bien ses
marchés avec plein d'autres animaux si
c'était stupide et dégueulasse peut
effectivement au bout d'un certain temps
j'ai finalement retrouvé sniper wolf
était connu comme étant l'avenir
il peut je dis bon
allez pouvoir venger la mort de merrill
enfin voir l'été pas morts on s'en fout
sniper d'élite contre un sniper d'élite
il fallait surtout pas révélé à
l'adversaire sa position mais où est
elle
elle était difficile à atteindre les
secteurs sont des gens toujours sur
leurs gardes
[Musique]
mais j'ai quand même réussi à l'avoir
très facilement j'avoué sniper wolf est
venue mourir dans mes bras ses sicaires
quoi tu me crois pas alors que 6,6 me
mauger cameroun et je suis dit sur un
champ de bataille
[Musique]
mais c'est pas vrai jeune gars du clair
arrêtez moi sérieux après dix minutes de
psychothérapie j'ai enfin pu reprendre
mon combat un j'affrontais un autre des
lieutenants de liquides un chaman corps
bouge pas en quoi mais grâce à mon
immense talent de fuite un
lance-roquette avec plein de munitions
j'ai pu mettre fin aux combats
non et là soudain tout a été chamboulé
par une révélation soudaine le docteur
now winter qui m'aidait depuis le début
n'était pas le docteur naomi hunter
dormi je ne peux pas croire que vous
m'ayez traille qui êtes vous
je n'en suis pas sûr je ne sais ni à un
accord
j'ai acheté mon identité je m'en fous de
mon été les problèmes job paul savoie
[ __ ] comment on enlève ce truc m'a
trouvé en rhodésie dans les années 80 la
rhodésie qu'on appelle maintenant le
zimbabwe oui bof
juppé ni au camembert c'est sans doute
de là que vient ma couleur de peau mais
je ne suis pas sûr alors je comprends je
suis camerounais
enfin ma mère était sénégalaise mais mon
père était qu'un monet allez les lions
indomptables n'est pire encore mon
maître miller n'était pas mon maître
miller s'était liquid snake tu est en
train de parler à à moi moore très cher
frère et là tu me reconnais
non
[Musique]
liquid snake et j'avoue que le fait
qu'il avait exactement la même tête que
moi m'avait un petit peu mis la puce à
l'oreille mais je pense et le dire je
suis timide
et puis en fait j'ai été manipulé par
mon maître mais qui était pas vos
maîtres mais qu'était mon clown et kim
avait manipulé pour trouver l'école de
mise à feu
reste le chef du darpa al c'est lui là
mais en fait c'était pas le chef du
darpa
c'est un ninja psig physique des
cybernétique qui était en fait gris fox
qui avait absorbé le sens du chef du dap
attend massage confondre acheter des
coyotes depuis ce matin ce qui me déjà
un peu glauque de ninja c'est à dire le
fait en fait en fait c'est le frère de
nairobi que j'avais vaincu à zanzibar
qui se faisait appeler franck jagger jeu
fait il voulait me tuer mais il mesurer
parce qu'il voulait que ce soit lui qui
me tue depuis on s'en branle à la baston
compte de rambo mais pas pu tirer des
roquettes sur un tank avec des missiles
nucléaires
écoutez moi la paix dieu m'en fous et
papy comment ça s'est terminé finalement
assez bien bien plus tard et j'ai
retrouvé mon papounet d'un cimetière
papa je t'avais pas reconnu mes papilles
il n'était pas censé être mort et toi
pourquoi tu es aussi vieux que lui et
pour finir explique qu on avait discuté
échangé nos techniques secrètes parce
qu'un garde un carton comme ça là tu
peux décider une meuf dessus et là les
gardes mais ils voient que du feu
attention ça sent la pisse mais papy
c'est pas une histoire ça c'est un jeu
vidéo quoi qui chante qui m'appuyer
dessus alors un nom bien sûr mais je
sera pour la prochaine fois
[Musique]
m